the russian economy is in free fall
economists to jpmorgan chase expect the
russian economy to contract a whopping
7 this year goldman sachs thinks the
damage could be worse predicting a 9
contraction in the russian economy
virtually every major corporation in the
world has stopped doing business in
russia
bp shell and exxonmobil have pulled out
of energy deals apple google and
facebook have blocked the kremlin from
their platforms
cnn has stopped broadcasting in russia
which shows that not everything is so
bad in that country every storm cloud
has a silver lining
but other than not having to stare at
brian stelter anymore things are going
about as poorly in russia as they
possibly could
by targeting russia's central bank with
sanctions an unprecedented tactic the
west has collapsed the russian ruble
nearly two-thirds of the 630 billion
dollars in the central bank's foreign
exchange reserves were frozen overnight
a financial expert summed up his take on
the situation by drinking live on
russian television to the death of their
stock market
worst case scenario he says i'm going to
go work at santa claus like i did 25
years ago
jokes aside let's do this quickly
send regards to sergey ushenko who drank
12 13 years ago to the death of the
stock market
today i'm drinking carbonated water dear
stock market you were close to us you
are interesting
rest in peace dear comrade
the host says i'm not going to comment
on this stunt because i don't want to
believe it
the west just wrecked russia
and with good reason
vladimir putin invaded a smaller weaker
neighboring country
whatever the nuances nothing comes
anywhere near justifying an all-out
russian invasion
nothing could justify the shelling of
civilian centers
and yet
putin's main domestic political rival
has complained that we in the west keep
falling into putin's traps
we might be doing it again
there are lots of people right now on
the left and the right clamoring to send
russia back to the stone age with
sanctions or missiles or both
the economic crisis we've inflicted is
already 40 to 80 percent worse than
russia's last worst economic catastrophe
in 1998.
some analysts predict it could
eventually be three times worse than the
collapse of 1998 when russia defaulted
on its debt
the economic catastrophe coincidentally
that launched putin to power in the
first place
the white house is confident that joe
biden's got everything under control
i was at the state department the
president was the vice president the
last time russia invaded ukraine this is
a pattern of horror from this president
from president putin and from the
cronies around him this is a pattern
this is a pattern of horror do you see
the pattern the pattern is that every
time biden goes up against putin putin
wins
the white house wants regime change in
russia
it worked out so well in iraq and egypt
and libya why not give it another go in
a nuclear former superpower without any
clear popular opposition leader what
could go wrong
but even if it's the right idea to take
putin out our leaders may very well have
just entrenched him or maybe someone
even worse in power
those who don't know history are doomed
to repeat it unfortunately our current
crop of rulers don't seem to know
anything at all i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from how dare you
who says if michael keeps saying i told
you so we shall call him nostradamus
many people are doing that already i'm
i'm not saying i'm doing that i'm saying
many people are calling me nostradamus
because
it would appear i'm noticing a pattern
of seeing through the liberal lies and
propaganda i can just see through things
that are frequently difficult to see
through i can see through my window
treatments and when you want really good
window treatments i would strongly
recommend you check out hunter douglas
right now go to hunterdouglas.com
i did not realize back when i was an
ignorant bachelor how important window
treatments are for your home i don't
think i'm exaggerating when i say window
treatments might be the single most
important thing you can do for your home
because window treatments determine how
the light comes into your home and the
light hitting your home is what makes it
so beautiful hunter douglas can help you
they've got innovative window shade
designs gorgeous fabrics control systems
so advanced they can be scheduled to
automatically adjust to their optimal
position throughout the day maybe it's
the way the shades diffuse harsh
sunlight to cast a beautiful glow across
the room or being able to enjoy the view
outside the window while protecting your
privacy inside maybe it's the superior
insulation that shades provide keeping
you warmer in winter
cooler in summer and lowering utility
bills something really important right
now
whatever it is head on over to
hunterdouglas.com
knowles today get your free style get
smarter design guide with fresh takes
creative ideas and smart solutions for
dressing your windows hunterdouglas.com
knowles head on over there for your free
design guide a lot of people
have a lot of opinions about russia i'm
not i am not pretending to be a russia
expert or a ukraine expert but i think i
might be the only blue check on social
media who is not an overnight russia and
ukraine expert
i think i might be the only person
on social media
who doesn't claim to have all of the
answers for this many centuries-long
regional conflict
between russia and ukraine
unfortunately though it's not only the
blue checks who are going crazy it's
it's
some of our elected leaders too you
expect it from the blue chicks you
expect expect it from hollywood patricia
arquette who is she's an actress she's
won some awards i forget what movies
she's been in she blocked me on twitter
but she's very left-wing she tweeted out
her solution to the ukraine conflict she
said quote
kick russia out of nato
now uh nato of course is a treaty
organization
whose sole purpose
is to oppose russia so obviously russia
is is not in nato russia could not be in
nato
uh that would that would take away the
very purpose of nato and yet i suspect
that patricia arquette is not much more
ignorant on this subject than most
people
around there bette midler another
wonderful uh actress of a certain age
with very certain political opinions she
tweeted out
a picture of vladimir zelensky the
leader of ukraine in the obama 2008
style that kind of artistic adjective
prop style that says hope underneath it
zielinski he's standing firm he's
displaying a great deal of courage and
heroism sure
what are the odds do you think that
bette midler could point to ukraine on a
map
forget what are the ads that bette
midler could tell you anything about
vladimor zelinski including his first
name
could tell you anything about the
oligarchy in ukraine could tell you
anything about their political system
whatsoever
do you think she could even identify the
country on a map absolutely not of
course not
and yet she is so enthusiastic she's so
gung-ho she knows exactly what this is
about what we need to do
we need to exalt silence
we need to do everything we can to
punish russia widespread economic
sanctions destroy the central bank
regime change in russia it's not just
her lindsey graham a sitting united
states senator said what what he
believes the solution is
is to to hire someone to find someone to
put a bullet in putin's head
how does this end
somebody in russia
has to step up to the plate is there
brutus in russia is there more
successful colonel stoppenberg in the
russian military the only way this [ __ ]
ends my friend is for somebody in russia
to take this guy out you would be doing
your country a great service and the
world of great service
lindsey graham of course has never seen
a regime on earth that he does not want
to topple and vladimir putin is a really
bad guy okay i get it i get why people
would want to go assassinate putin
now let me ask you the next question and
maybe it's a question we should have
asked before we insisted on regime
change in libya or egypt or iraq or
syria although that one actually didn't
work because assad held on to power let
me ask you this question what happens
next
what happens next
you take out putin okay i'm with you
then who takes over the extremely
chaotic historically corrupt nuclear
former superpower who assumes power
do you have
none of these people have any answers i
suspect
lindsey graham might have an answer that
the smart set washington dc answer is
the person who takes power is alexei
navalny alexei navalny is a relatively
pro-western opposition leader he's been
putin's thorne and putin side for many
years now putin has jailed him so
navalny is in prison he's the one who
says that we keep falling into putin's
hands
alexi navalny i have i've got a poll
right here
of alexei navalny's approval and
disapproval ratings this is from uh uh
levada this is the levada center which
is not a pro it's a russian center it's
not pro putin actually a lot of putin's
associates want to blacklist lovato from
russia as a foreign agent that's trying
to topple his regime okay so this is as
hostile to putin as it gets approved
disapprove on the only opposition leader
in in russia
approve
and this is between 18 to 24 year olds
25 to 39 year olds 40 to 54 year olds
and 55 plus approved 24 22
11 among people in their 40s
or 8 among people 55 plus
what are the disapproved numbers
59 51 69
67
the numbers don't work this guy's about
as popular as joe biden is in america
so depending on how they conduct the
election maybe navalny could win he's
not popular this is not a viable option
especially if we're talking about
getting rid of the corrupt oligarchy and
bringing democracy to russia and then
we'll all live peacefully that's not
going to work
so i
i get the the good intentions here we
want to destroy russia's economy we've
never destroyed a country's economy like
we're destroying russia right now make
them suffer make putin sweat and and
then what
and then what
it was a devastating economic collapse
that brought putin to power in the first
place
if anything i suspect these sanctions
have probably strengthened putin's grip
on power now it might destroy the
economy so much that he just can't keep
funding the war
but i don't think this is going to lead
to regime change
this is something conservatives know
that
liberals and more uh
adventurous sorts of politicians don't
seem to get
sometimes the devil you know is better
than the devil you don't thankfully
libya was not a superpower a nuclear
superpower never it was never a
superpower but luckily it was it was not
a nuclear power when we took out gaddafi
but what if it had been do we do we
think that libya is better today after
regime change i don't egypt i don't iraq
even probably not
what are we do i know we have good
intentions with these russian sanctions
with trying to push regime change in in
russia i know it's good intentions the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
now kamala harris has
much more important matters to deal with
than the war in ukraine
a
uh former superpower threatening nuclear
holocaust on the world she's got much
more important things to deal with
namely the equality act
yes
the equality act
is this rule this law that the left is
pushing to redefine
men as women and women as men and and
create civil rights protections for
gender identity and sexual orientation
she says let's send the equality act to
president biden's desk
we must increase protections for lgbtq
plus americans across the country the
onslaught of state bills targeting
transgender americans and their families
is wrong we must we don't we just don't
talk about lgbt enough in america right
that's our problem we don't talk about a
very very small percentage of people
with eccentric sexual desires and
preferences and ideologies we don't talk
about that enough we don't have um
two full months of the year dedicated to
talking about it we don't have every
corporation in the country and school
and many churches frankly flying rainbow
flags all the time to talk about a
handful of eccentric sexual desires no
no we need to talk about it more
not everything has to be gay
not everything okay not every single
thing in the country has to be gay
except it does
except it does
you know the
the
conservative
answer to the insanely aggressive lgbt
push over in recent decades which has
now led to redefining marriage for
goodness sakes for the first time ever
in this kind of radical way redefining
sex itself getting rid of women's
bathrooms getting rid of women's sports
it's it's been so aggressive and what
the conservatives have said is look do
whatever you want frankly i don't really
care that much what you do in the
privacy of your own home just uh
don't make it
a public thing don't make me participate
in it and that was always going to be a
losing strategy
when people now respond i think it was
blake masters the the republican senate
candidate in where is it arizona who
said
not everything has to be gay every
actually i mean i love blake masters is
a terrific candidate
but the joke there is everything does
have to be gay and everything has to be
gay because this is not really about
sexual preference or some long oppressed
minority
this is about
the left's entire animating ideology of
liberation
what the left is after
is liberation i know that seems a little
bit weird because the left is always
talking about equality and it's the
right that's always talking about
liberty
but the left is after liberation too
well the right is after liberation from
taxes and government regulations the
left is after a deeper kind of
liberation
liberation from tradition
liberation from social roles free the
women from the kitchen
free
the
oppressed racial minorities from their
condition
from their legal strictures against them
free
even beyond the law even beyond
tradition
free the
men who think they're women from having
to actually be men free people from
biology free people from nature free
people from reality this is not a
moderate kind of political liberation to
change some rules about the way
different groups are treated this is
about a fundamental assault on
nature
if liberation is now about forcing
everyone right coercing everyone to
pretend that men who are confused are
actually women
that is a liberation that demands being
freed from reality itself as whitaker
chambers said it's the second oldest
ideology in the world it goes back to
the garden of eden when the serpent told
eve ye shall be his gods you can create
your own realities what anthony kennedy
said in the uh planned parenthood versus
casey decision now 30 years ago he said
that at the heart of liberty is the
right to define your own concept of
existence
antonin scalia made fun of this as the
sweet mystery of life passage
i don't know where in the constitution
it says that you've got the right to
define your own concept of existence
obviously you don't
defining your own concept of existence
is what little confused children do when
they play pretend in the backyard that's
not what adults do that's not what
rational educated people do if they want
to live in society but that is the
ideology and so it won't stop it can't
stop even at the brink of world war
three kamala harris has to talk about
transgenderism because that is the next
step that is at the heart of this they
people have to talk about the metaverse
we have to talk about
transhumanism frankly we need to talk
about liberating ourselves from every
single bond including the natural ones
everything's got to be gay so i learned
from metro magazine
this article's a little old but it's
making the rounds again and i had to
bring it up i couldn't miss it metro
magazine
informed me of something that was pretty
uh
pretty surprising
straight men in bromances kiss
cuddle and stand around naked together
didn't know that
a bromance has been defined as an
emotionally intense bond between
straight men in the conclusion of this
study it's very very scientific
the authors wrote they spoke about their
desire to cuddle and hug with their
bromantic friends
some agree that this was the case when
asked whereas others offered it
unsolicited as as part of their
definition of bromance in all 29 of the
30 men who took part in the study
said they had cuddled with their
bromantic partner this latest work backs
a 2012 study that found 89 percent of
145 surveyed undergraduate heterosexual
men had kissed
he kissed their their bros their bro the
bros
straight men most straight men the vast
majority of straight men
kiss and cuddle with their friends and
stand around naked right
now look i'm no scientist
okay i don't have an advanced degree in
statistics or sociology or whatever
i don't think straight men do this
maybe look this is a british paper and
the brits have always been a little bit
light in the loafers that way so maybe
that's possible i just don't think it's
the case
i think
actually ontology tells us that's not
the case i think the nature of being a
straight man tells you that's not the
case because by definition
straight men would not hang around and
kiss and cuddle with their friends this
is something i wrote about in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which i became a number one
national bestseller last year thanks to
you and it's coming out in paper back
again and i really want to jump up the
charts so that i can stick in the eye of
the new york times anyway that's a
digression i talked about how the left
gains power by redefining words well you
see it here
straight men
used to be men the definition of a
straight man was men who don't cuddle
and kiss their male friends
and now the left is redefining straight
man to
man who kisses and cuddles with his male
friends
so now there are no straight men this is
this is erasure
this is this is the way they take
control
of society on the left they just
redefine everything and they have to
don't think this is some diversion i
think this is a trap that the
the right actually fell into this with
political correctness they said oh who
cares political correctness isn't a big
deal it's kind of a silly distraction
for more important things like cutting
taxes and getting new free trade deals
oh forget that they're redefining women
and redefining men and redefining our
whole country and redefining the
founding is evil and you know forget
about that for a second let's just focus
on cutting taxes and manufacturing more
stuff in china and that'll help gdp and
that's all that matters no this is this
is the issue
frankly the war in ukraine is a
distraction
and and kamala harris knows it and the
left knows it
we should learn it too speaking of
gay men and the uh war in ukraine it's a
strange
strange uh transition perhaps uh george
takei george takei has a message for all
of the impoverished
struggling families out there who are
making really difficult decisions who
can't make ends meet because the price
of everything is going up and especially
the price of gas he says
suck it up
quote
americans we can endure higher prices
for food and gas if it means putting the
screws to putin consider it a patriotic
donation in the fight for freedom over
tyranny
more piercing
political commentary from hollywood you
had bette midler you had patricia
arquette now you have commander darth
vader or something i don't know i'm not
a huge sci-fi fan i guess he was on star
trek george takei says suck it up
now i'm not surprised he's this guy is
obviously completely out of touch he's
an elderly man without children who is a
multi-millionaire he doesn't need to
worry about money he doesn't know the
cost of anything i'm sure he has
assistance do all of his shopping for
him anyway so it's not a big deal
for families who have let's say multiple
kids who are who don't have that good
star trek paycheck coming in uh probably
it's a little tougher okay but george
takei he doesn't care about that he
doesn't understand that that's not
surprising what's shocking to me in this
tweet is one word one the word is
patriotic he says it's a patriotic
donation
if you screw up your own country's
economy to help this issue in ukraine to
fight against russia in this regional
conflict patriotic how is it patriotic
am i a citizen of ukraine i don't think
so
what he's what george takei is saying is
that ukraine is a part of america
ironically what george takei is
saying here is that vladimir putin's
right that ukraine actually is just an
american client state that america has
this broad sweeping empire it's spread
out all over the world now it's right up
on russia's border and russia is taking
defensive action just like america would
if russia had invaded mexico and mexico
were a russian client state now i'm not
i don't think that that's exactly the
situation that we're looking at but
ironically that is what george takei is
saying that is what a lot of the left is
saying and they want to have it both
ways and they can't that's magical
thinking on the one hand they want
america to be the empire over all the
world they want america to rule and
crush local cultures and crush local
desires and impose our will on the world
and then on the other they think america
is evil and terrible and they don't want
us forcing other countries to do a damn
thing
and they don't want us getting involved
in any other country on earth and they
want us to mind our own business and
actually they want us to give the land
back to the indians
they want two completely opposite things
and they want them both at the same time
which is why their commentary is so
confused but this is a problem not just
for idiots in hollywood this is a
problem in america it's a kind of
schizophrenia in the american foreign
policy and we go back and forth and back
and forth and it's why we keep messing
up our own
interests around the world
this thursday night march 10th we're
premiering yet another
movie
i cannot wait to share this one with you
the movie is called the hyperions it's
exactly what entertainment in hollywood
is missing these days
it's not woke it's got zero underlying
partisan message it's just an excellent
film
because when it comes to entertainment
that's really what matters check out the
trailer
good day hyperion club members
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
i watched the movie on saturday night
it's terrific i really i really love
this movie we're going to be streaming
the movie once on march 10th for all of
youtube to see this is the last time we
will be premiering a movie on youtube so
be sure to head over to dailywire
the youtube channel for the live showing
and then head over to dailywire.com
subscribe so that you don't miss any
more of our growing cache of content
that we've got to offer
also we've got a new show coming up it's
the comments section streaming now it
features our newest addition to the dw
lineup of hosts brett cooper the comment
section is an irreverent viral content
and news review show that offers an
against the grain laid back perspective
on all the insanity of today and will
even take you into one of the scariest
places the online world has to offer the
comments section
the show is streaming now on youtube for
all to see make sure you subscribe to
the comment section brett cooper click
the notification bell so you don't miss
it we'll be right back with a lot more
george takei and lots of other hollywood
liberals and actually the white house
and the entire ruling class they say
look your gas is going up because of our
stupid energy policy and our stupid
policy on russia and ukraine and yeah we
bungled it all and now we're going to
bungle it even more and we're going to
send gas going even further up through
the roof but hey just suck it up that's
your patriotic duty and biden can afford
it and saki can afford it and george
takei and bette midler and patricia
arquet they can all afford it but
most americans cannot like
mothers in michigan who've got to decide
between filling up their gas tanks and
buying clothing for their kids
it has consumers like mother of two
lauren strickstein watching their
budgets it's a horrible situation i'm
scared for how high the prices are gonna
go and keisha townsend of southfield is
too yeah cause you gotta you need gas to
get to work and stuff like that so yeah
you to cut back on the certain things
just to get you know get some gas and
stuff yeah i have to think about
putting gasoline
prices before
buying my kids clothes right now
see these are really hard decisions for
americans and to what end
to what end we covered this on the show
last week
joe biden
shut down american
energy shut down american oil pipelines
to support a russian oil pipeline called
nordstrom ii a russian oil pipeline that
gave russia a direct route to the
european oil market that cut out the
middleman of ukraine which essentially
rolled out the red carpet for putin to
invade ukraine and we all knew that that
was going to happen
and conservatives weren't joe biden
about this and that's why there were
sanctions in place in the first place
that joe biden intentionally and lobbied
really hard to get removed then
putin literally invades or biden
literally invades putin to invade he
says look if it's just a minor incursion
it's not a big deal we won't really do
anything putin does invade
now we put the sanctions back on the
pipeline sanctions that joe biden made a
point of removing that if we just left
them in place putin almost certainly
wouldn't have invaded we put the
sanctions back on we then put way more
sanctions on russia and it sends
american gas through the roof again and
the white house all the while says no
we're not going to drill here no we're
not going to build more pipelines no
we're going to try to get off of oil why
so now we're going to import more
iranian oil we're pre until just a few
days ago we were importing more russian
oil what to stop climate change because
russian oil doesn't tick off the sun
gods iranian oil isn't bad for the
climate no it's only american oil we can
burn any we can burn the oil here it's
just only when the american oil gets
burned that's what irritates the sun
monster and brings on armageddon does
any of that make sense what's the what's
the upshot of it what's the end end of
it well the end of it is that these
mothers can't afford to buy their kids
clothing because of this stupid policy
it's like the stupidest policy they
could possibly make and the reason for
that policy
is not even that biden has a totally
formed ideology that he's just
ruthlessly pursuing
he's not the problem actually is that
they keep vacillating they keep going
back and forth
the problem is
that if you stand in the middle of the
road you're going to get hit by a truck
we want the we want the sanctions on the
pipeline we don't want the sanctions on
the pipeline we want putin to be able to
invade we don't want him to be able to
we this that this that
back and forth and back and forth and it
comes down to
what george takei
does america want to be a global empire
where ukraine really is part of america
and we're going to defend it just like
it were idaho
and an attack on ukraine is an attack on
all americans or does america want to
mind its own business
and not really have all these
commitments around the world
and not be the world's police and not
occupy libya and iraq and syria and all
these other places and then allow i
don't know russia to move in or allow
china to move in and allow these
world powers to grow and grow and grow
and challenge american hegemony and oops
we don't like that so now we're going to
go back in again and we go back and
forth and back and forth sometimes
actually a wrong decision is better than
indecision this indecision is causing a
lot of problems
you see now we're leaning much more in
the america world police the american
empire we're the globalist regime and
everyone needs to submit to us nancy
pelosi just held a photo op on the steps
of the capitol she
she desecrated an american flag for this
photo op she was holding up with a lot
of other lawmakers there were probably a
couple squish republicans in there too
holding up this flag it's an american
flag but the bottom of the flag is not
red and white stripes
it's yellow and blue stripes
as if to say
america and ukraine are the same thing i
pledge allegiance to ukraine
and the united
countries of the american empire
that's what she's saying here
you know new york texas tennessee
california they each just get stars
ukraine gets half the flag
a violation of the flag code not that
anyone really cares about that anymore
especially on the left you'll remember
during the hillary clinton presidential
campaign the the campaign took a picture
of a flag crumpled up thrown on the
ground they thought it looked kind of
artsy and cool no sense that that's
wrong it's actually wrong to do to your
country not not surprising actually to
an american left which now regularly
desecrates and disrespects the flag but
this is some crazy thinking
i don't think the most war hockey
bullish neocon george w bush cowboy
would support this kind of radicalism to
say actually our half of our country is
just ukraine now that's what we care
about
that's but that's what pelosi is saying
that's what a lot of people are saying
that's not the kind of system our
constitution sets up but then the left
will go even further and they'll say
that our constitution is trash they will
literally say that on the view ellie
mistahl who you may have seen him on
msnbc or cnn actually you probably
haven't because you don't watch those
channels but
but he's he writes for the nation he's a
left-wing political analyst of some
prominence ellie mistahl goes on he's
speaking to the cackling hens on the
view they're saying clock clock clock
and then somehow the constitution comes
up and eliminal he comes out and says
the quiet part out loud he says he hates
the constitution
some will say okay so are you arguing
for throwing out the constitution should
the constitution be thrown out what do
we do is it a living document is it a or
is it a sacred document it's certainly
not sacred all right let's start there
the constitution is kind of trash now
let's just again let's just talk as
adults first what did you say it's why
it's kind of trash
it was it was written by slavers and
colonists and white people who were
willing to make deals with slavers and
colonists they didn't ask anybody like
me what they thought about the
constitution
let's talk like adults for a second yes
nothing says talking like an adult like
ellie mistahl
on the view yes that how how mature how
responsible and sophisticated
certainly not sacred our constitution
and it's kind of trash he's talking like
a a freshman in high school let's talk
like adults it's kind of trash
and then joy behar you look over joy
behar
pretty left-wing pretty
disrespectful of america in many ways
she hears this and even she she goes
what did you say
it's you said it's trash
when you are too far left
for joy behar you have gone really far
but
i suspect elimistal is actually
representing the accurate perception of
the constitution on the left
i don't think he's just some crazy
fringe element i mean the left has been
telling us this for years they protest
the american flag on football fields and
elsewhere they
denigrate the founding fathers and
framers of the constitution as he does
as slavers they're slavers
so that's why they
everything they ever touched was
terrible and turned to ash like this
wonderful country that has allowed me to
prosper even me ellie mistahl a dum-dum
uh they're trash it's total trash
of course you know you notice the people
who denigrate our forebears they never
look at the things we're doing right now
that our posterity might say about us
they they never imagine that some some
day hundreds of years from now
people will look back at ellie mistahl
and the women of the view and say these
people were trash they defended killing
almost a million babies a year and they
pretended it was some sort of sacred
right
these people are trash
you know you want to compare
the founders and the framers to anyone
at least they weren't killing a million
babies a year okay
actually whatever the and also by the
way
most of the founders and framers
virtually all of them had deep moral
misgivings about slavery and a lot of
them wanted to get rid of it even at the
time of the constitution it was just
politically impossible putting that
aside
if you're if you're comparing heaps of
trash you know everyone's trash
all fall short of the glory of god all
sin everyone's trash would seem to me
that
the view and ellie mestall certainly
beats the
founders and framers in magnitude and
stench of the trash
but the battle right now
you'll notice is over not the
constitution when ellie mistel says the
constitution is terrible and trash
he doesn't actually make an argument
about the constitution he makes an
argument about the people who wrote the
constitution and he says these were bad
people therefore throw out the
constitution so the and and
this is this is defined you know it's
it's actually a pretty telling clip even
though the things that he's saying are
extremely stupid it's telling because
that's what our battle over who we are
as a country has been about it's not
really about the principles of the
constitution
on the rare occasion that someone brings
up a principle of the constitution they
usually do so to misrepresent it they'll
say you know in the constitution slaves
were only counted as three-fifths of
people can you believe that those
racists those well do you know what the
three-fifths compromise was do you know
what the point of that was yeah
yeah they said the founders said that
the slaves were three-fifths and well
actually there were two groups one group
wanted the slaves to be counted as fully
as people and the other group didn't
want the slaves to be counted as people
as at all
and the the group that wanted the slaves
to be counted fully as people were the
slavers
usually people who invoke the
three-fifths compromise as some terrible
aspect of american history don't realize
that it was the slaveholders who wanted
the slaves to be counted as fully as
people because they wanted more
representation in the congress
in no small part to better entrenched
slavery it was the
northerners and the people who opposed
slavery who didn't want the slaves to be
counted at all because they wanted to
reduce the influence of the southern
slave holding states in
the government
so on the rare occasion that someone
brings up a provision of the
constitution it's usually just to
misrepresent it usually the battle is
over the founders and the framers
jefferson
had slaves
and washington had slaves and so the
founders were bad
and then on the right you have people
say no the founders were really good and
they were smart and they gave us a good
country and therefore
because the founders were good and the
framers were good we should support the
constitution and on the left they say no
because the founders of the framers were
bad we should oppose the constitution
there is a third way here though
and i think this would be the better way
for
conservatives to defend our country
the left has already done a great job in
the cultural battle
of tearing down the statues of
denigrating washington and jefferson and
lincoln actually the refounding of the
country
what if we focus on the principles
themselves and what if we focus on our
constitutional system and and the law in
general not just as some random
preference of some old guys in the late
18th century
a preference that could be good or bad
depending on your view of these guys
what if we view the law as something
that is objective
that is objectively true what if we
start making points like hey
the commandment thou shalt not commit
murder is just true it's true whether
dudes in philadelphia think it's true or
not it's it's a part of the natural law
it's a part of the transcendent moral
order that is just always true and from
that natural law we get other laws more
particular laws that you might call it
the law of nations adrian vermeuel the
conservative harvard law professor has a
good book out about this and from the
law after the law of nations at the
smaller level you have the civil law
and then we have the particular laws
that we all make in our own towns and
states and in our own countries
but what if the process of of law
we're not so much making law just
pulling it out of thin air but what if
it were actually discovering law that
some things are true whether we whether
we want them to be whether we don't want
them to be what if we ground our defense
of america and that some things are just
true and some things are just good and
it's not about the personal virtues or
foibles of any founders or framers it's
about what's good and what's true what
if we had the guts to actually say that
and defend that you're seeing the
parents do this now the parents are
going into these schools and they're
talking to phd administrators who have
advanced degrees and great experience in
critical race theory and have studied
all this kind of kooky academic ideology
crt transgenderism and these parents are
going in and they say look i don't give
a damn about your stupid degrees i don't
care how many years you spent studying
these lunatics it's just wrong it's just
wrong it's just bad and wrong and ugly
and we're not going to have it
i think that would put us
on much sounder footing it would allow
us to oppose
the caprice and the
the
absolute arbitrariness of the way we are
ruled right now
the way we've been ruled for two years
in particular has been purely arbitrary
and now the left wants you to believe
right now that that that's over we're
moving
kovit is over the rule of the dr fauci's
that's totally over don't worry we're
getting back to normal never mind
nothing to see here move on move on move
on do not let them lull you into
complacency their arbitrary capricious
rule is not even close to over and
they're even admitting it if you know
where to look
they're telling us now
on the left because their poll numbers
are in the trash that
that covid it's okay it's over we're
gonna lift some restrictions don't worry
dr fauci he's not on tv quite as much
anymore
don't worry don't be angry about us for
locking your kids away from home and
sticking them with experimental drugs
for two years and not letting you have
weddings and funerals and see your loved
ones and go to work and for tanking the
economy and for
effectively booting out the president
that who is relatively popular and
taking away your right to go to church
and taking away so many of your
liberties and and
i'm sorry
never mind we're moving on forget about
it
until november
until november don't don't let them lull
you into believing that kovid
and the kovid regime and the rule of dr
fauci is over it's not over it's just
really really unpopular right now in an
election year but it's not over and
they're admitting it
here's here's a headline just from the
past few days
top new york city officials call for
student covid 19 vaccine mandate by next
school year so they're they're relaxing
it right now they're starting to relax
it right now even in new york
but they want it back next year they
want it back next year because after the
midterm elections they can pull all this
crap again new york times
the surgeon general calls on big tech to
turn over covid19 misinformation data
so the surgeon general the biden
administration
is calling on social media companies to
turn over all of your data on whoever
dissented even once from the dr fauci
regime
for what purpose so that they can just
store it away in a drawer and not look
at it no to punish you to investigate
anyone who dissented in any way
if this were over if the dr fauci rule
if the covid rule were over would they
be demanding this information of course
not it would it would have no purpose
but they are demanding it because it's
not over new york times politico
senate votes to end covet 19 emergency
declaration
biden threatens veto wait a second i
thought this was over i thought we were
moving on i thought we had to focus on
ukraine i thought we had to focus on
energy prices i thought it's not over
it's not over i actually had forgotten
that they still had the emergency
declaration
because it's it's been so it's
ridiculous
some of us
i know that the commenter at the top of
the show called me nostradamus thank you
very much some of us called this two
years ago and said they're never going
to give you your power back unless you
take it back dr fauci is never going to
let up unless you fire dr fauci unless
you call your congressman and senator
and have them sign the michael knowles
public health protection pledge to make
sure that you investigate subpoena and
zero out dr fauci's salary when the
republicans retake the house
if they're not going to give your power
back to you unless you take it
well they still have this emergency
declaration why is biden threatening to
veto this
he's almost certainly going to veto this
why it's over
omicron is down the delta's down
we don't need to wear the masks yet we
kind of do we do have to wear the masks
on airplanes and on trains and in
government buildings and hold on wait
it's like it's not over
it's like they're just trying to lull us
into a false sense of complacency so
that we can just they can hold on to
power just a little bit longer and then
they're gonna do it all again those
three articles that's just from march
3rd that's just from what two three days
ago
that's it
more more coming out every day if you
know where to look eric adams the mayor
of new york is is demanding that
children under five years old
mask up because they can't vaccinate
three-year-olds need to mask up
three-year-olds who
are at virtually no risk from the
coronavirus
and pose virtually no risk to anybody
else they're still
clinging on
don't let them get away with this they
are so slippery they're so good at
evading responsibility
jen saki at the white house is being
asked hey hey jensaki how come the whole
country is turning to ash ever since joe
biden got elected how come just to name
the most immediate problem for us how
come gas is going through the roof and
what's biden going to do about it
the reason why the price of gas is going
up is not because of steps the president
has taken they are because president
putin is invading ukraine and that is
creating a great deal of instability in
the global marketplace
sure
the reason the price of gas going up
is not because of steps that might
mistaken though actually there are some
steps that biden took like killing the
oil pipelines that are causing gas
rights but no it's not because of steps
that biden took it's because putin is
invading ukraine
because of steps that biden took that's
why putin's invading ukraine
because biden did that because biden
literally told him to
explicitly told him he could invade your
grain
and now gas is going up and it is
biden's fault but a lot of
a lot of people in this country who tune
in only to
cnn and the washington post and nbc and
cbs and whatever
they're going to believe that they're
going to say it's putin's fault right
why is it putin's fault because of what
biden
is doing
these guys are pretty radical the ruling
class is pretty radical you want to hear
an example of this we usually think of
the supreme court as being one of the
moderating influences in america
they never quite give the conservatives
what they want even the liberals haven't
totally been happy in recent years with
the court
the supreme court just ruled to
reinstate the death penalty for the
boston marathon bomber
so you remember the boston marathon
bomber this guy they got him dead to
rights he planned the attack he killed
people he injured lots of other people
and he he got the death sentence
then an appeals court
took away the death sentence in 2020 for
this guy
why because they said oh well he uh
maybe his brother who he committed the
attack with maybe his brother was more
responsible than he was so anyway let's
take away the death penalty
basically for nowhere they just didn't
want to kill him because they don't like
the death penalty so that goes up to the
supreme court
and
the supreme court makes the right
decision but we have a six three
conservative court that means that three
justices three liberals on the supreme
court which are supposed to be the most
moderate normal reasonable people in the
country
at least in politics
they
decided that they didn't want
the
boston marathon bomber an actual
terrorist in america who killed people
who injured children they didn't want
him to receive the death penalty that he
already received it's not even like the
supreme court had to decide well
you know what should we put him 30 years
in prison should we give him the death
penalty no he was already sentenced to
the death penalty the supreme court just
had to say okay that's fine and three
judges wouldn't do that that's how
radical
we're talking here okay
that's how blinded by ideology these
people are
all right this we are in a very tense
moment here where even the most elite
supposedly moderate reasonable liberals
are so
far out there
that they're basically not speaking the
same language as we are here in the
united states
and now we're running away in the next
panic and we're going to run away in the
next panic in the next panic in the next
panic and it's all with the best of
intentions and we all post the pictures
to social media and we all say i stand
with this new
cause and and i'm i'm now totally and
we're taking our eyes off the ball of
our own
domestic political troubles we're not
fixing our own country we're just being
swept away by ideology we're making
mistake after mistake after mistake
which is what happens to people who
don't know history i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show russia
calls off humanitarian deals and
ratchets up indiscriminate military
attacks vladimir putin cracks down on
descent threatens a wider war and the
west talks about shipping planes into
ukraine that's today on the ben shapiro
shall give it a listen